garnet chan here garnet is the brand
professor of chemistry at caltech
um
his his he works on uh
of course in theoretical chemistry but
at the intersection of that condensed
matter physics and quantum information
um so he has worked extensively on
assimilation of quantum many body
physics and
systems and quantum chemistry
both from the classical side and and
from the point of view of quantum
stimulation um
so i you know uh
i i have to say that i'm i'm
particularly looking forward to garnet's
uh garnet's talk uh
i i think um
uh
his uh
you know in in my uh
uh
uh you know in in in my experience he
he's been the one who has been
um you know most clear in expressing
uh you know the the
the the big picture as well as the
subtleties of of uh of the problems and
simulating quantum chemistry so
so
with that uh
garnett uh
looking forward to your talk
okay great
well thanks for the introduction
um and thanks for the invitation to
speak here to all of you
um and so you see the title of my talk
here is the evidence of exponential
content advantage in quantum chemistry
and you see at the bottom a very long
list of names
the content of this talk is is mainly
contained in a paper which we very
recently submitted
and many people contributed to uh
helping to improve the arguments within
the paper and and and so this is why you
see uh so many people uh there today so
uh on on this list here today so this
paper would not be possible without many
contributions okay but in case i i'll
get to business
um
and so um
we're going to be talking about the
quantum simulation of chemistry today
and
i think
usually the idea that one should be
using or one might use quantum devices
to simulate uh physical problems such as
chemical problems uh is usually traced
back to you know a comment from firemen
which has been repeated many times and
and i i i quote it here
you know fireman's comment is not
especially direct um but
today one has
more direct statements to the effect
that com computers are in fact
you know very well matched to problems
of chemistry simulation
um and because of this uh intense
interest you know it's of course then
important to really understand what the
advantages are
of simulating chemistry
on quantum devices and so that's the
subject of today's talk
okay so to proceed
i of course have to define quantum
chemistry in a more formal way
and quantum chemistry com is comprised
of many different computational tasks
um but probably
the most central one and certainly one
that people uh often talk about in this
and what is the starting point for many
other simulations
is computing the ground state of a
particular hamiltonian
the electronic hamiltonian describes the
physics of the electrons in the
molecules and in the materials
and the hamiltonian
has some particular form it contains the
kinetic energy of the electrons and the
coulomb interactions between them
and the external field of the nuclei
and we're going to be concerned with
computing the ground state eigenvalue
the so-called ground state energy
now the reason why the energy is so
important is because
from these energies you can deduce many
things for example if you take two
different configurations of molecules
you can subtract the energies you can
obtain the reaction energy
if you work with materials and you
compute the energies of different phases
you can understand the thermodynamic
stability
if you compute the energy as a function
of the nuclear coordinates that gives
you this thing called the potential
energy surface and this is essentially
what governs reaction dynamics or the
rates of reactions
and then finally of course if you
understand the energy as a function of
an external perturbation
that's a starting point for modeling
spectroscopy so computing the ground
state energy
is an important thing to do
um
now to make this something that we can
analyze the complexity of or talk about
the complexity of in a slightly simpler
way we i'll first discretize um the
problem of computing this
computing this eigenvalue and so for
this i'll introduce a single particle
basis
um and the basis size the size of the
single partial basis i'll call l and
that will be the problem size note that
the the many particle hilbert space is
then exponential in l okay so l refers
to the single particle basis size
and we'll be trying to understand the
complexity of this task as a function of
l
and
there are different ways of changing the
problem size that one can imagine
so in one case you might take a fixed
physical system for example a the neon
atom and as i increase l i might just
add more and more basis functions for
this single atom
that's sort of increasing the resolution
at which one is looking at the problem
so that's one way to increase l but but
today we're going to be thinking we'll
be thinking only about a different way
when i talk about increasing problem
size i'm actually also increasing the
physical size so i'm increasing the
number of atoms as well so when i
increase and increase l i mean more and
more atoms in the problem for a fixed
discretization per atom
and essentially what we then want to
understand is the complexity of
computing the ground state energy
for these for these hamiltonians as a
function of l
for something that i call
generic molecules and materials
and this term generic
is
both a very important term and also one
that is a little bit hard to
pin down as i'll explain
later
i'll say at this point in the talk that
as omash explains you know i'm a quantum
chemist i'm not a computer scientist
but i will try in this talk to talk
about things in a way that hopefully is
of interest to people in computer
science
okay so we want there to be you know
some advantage in this task for uh
quantum quantum computers um and so
how what is quantum advantage um so to
define quantity oh so first i should say
i will only be thinking about quantum
advantage uh for perfect quantum compute
so so we think everything will be
considering a case where the things are
fault tolerance and you can run the
quantum algorithm for an infinite amount
of time
so for so to define quantum advantage
however you need sort of a ratio of cos
because you need to know you also have
to have a classical counterpart
so the quantum ratio is really the cost
of the quantum
ground state algorithm versus the
classical groundsake algorithm
and we'll have a quantum advantage if
the numerator is smaller than the
denominator
now what you really want is an advantage
that sort of grows as your problem size
gets more complex as you increase the
problem size l
um
and a very desirable type of quantum
advantage is an exponential speeder
so
the exponential and exponential quantum
advantage of eqa
essentially says that the uh the quantum
speed up is exponential uh
in the problem size l
and the eqa hypothesis is that this type
of speedup is available for this ground
state quantum chemistry problem
in this world we'll be examining a
specific version of the eqa hypothesis
in particular we'll assume that the
quantum ratio takes the following form
that the numerator is polynomial in the
system size and the denominator is
exponential in the system size
for some given precision
epsilon
um here i'll break i'll say that
in different problems that different
notions of precision are
are appropriate so
for certain problems you care about the
absolute precision in the energy um but
for other problems uh typically things
in the thermodynamic limit
the relative precision is is really the
more useful metric um and that is just
the precision divided by l and i will
just i will distinguish between these
two by so by introducing a bar so
relative precision will be epsilon bar
so
uh so this talk is really about the
evidence supporting um uh what the
evidence is for this uk hypothesis uh in
this particular problem
okay so now let me get on to this
concept of generic um
and the reason why we have to introduce
this word generic is because
uh without any assumptions whatsoever
eqa as i've defined it
is impossible for this task
the reason is because we we are stating
we want this quantum ratio to take this
form where the cost of ground state
determination is polynomial for quantum
and exponential for classical
uh but we've known for quite a long time
i guess getting on to 20 years now from
uh the work of kitayev that that finding
ground states is not
is not something that's always easy on
quantum computing in fact there it's in
the class qma or loosely speaking you
know it can be exponentially hard
the intuition behind the existence of
these qma problems you might think of
them as essentially glassy like problems
like spin glass problems and these
problems have this characteristic where
for example if you were to just increase
the system size you know on the boundary
you can completely change the nature of
the ground state in the bulk um and
these problems are basically difficult
for quantum computers they're difficult
for classical computers
okay so if we want to talk about eqa
then in some ways we we need to sort of
exclude these problems um and perhaps
these problems aren't really very
relevant for typical chemistry or
generic chemistry and material sciences
this is perhaps a reasonable point of
view to hold okay so so we're going to
just assume that there exists some kind
of generic chemistry which excludes
these problems
and so in practice
generic chemistry is then quantumly easy
is a hypothesis
the problem is once you introduce these
types of exclusions or additional
assumptions uh it's it's possible that
they could introduce some loopholes for
classical algorithms to become efficient
as well
um
and so uh and so if you use this
additional additional information you
know you can you might be able to
construct classical heuristics uh where
these problems are also not so hard
um and so what we really need to
understand is the cost of quantum
algorithms on this class of circle
generic chemistry problems versus the
various classical heuristics that people
have proposed
to study to obtain ground state energies
so at this point i'm going to just
define you know the type of quantum
algorithm that i'm going to think that
we're going to examine um i'll say a
little bit about classical heuristics
and then we'll look at some of the
evidence
okay so first quantum americans for
ground state energies
well there's you know many of them these
days
but you know the most famous one is
is state preparation uh plus quantum
phase estimation so let me first talk
about that
um so this works basically in the
following steps
so first you have to prepare some
approximation to your ground state on
the quantum device so this is a state
preparation step
and then you measure the energy by the
phase estimation circuit
and this is a projective measurement so
you get an eigenstate of the hamiltonian
and of course then it may not be the
ground state so you have to repeat this
until the ground state is observed
um so the probability observing the
ground state is related to the state
that you prepare so a critical quantity
will be this overlap between uh the
prepared state phi
and the desired ground state cy naught
so our we
call this quantity s this is the symbol
we like to use in quantum chemistry and
sometimes i'll refer to the square of it
i'll call that the weight
now the complexity of this algorithm
takes the following form so you can
obtain the ground say energy with some
effort as polynomial in the inverse
overlap polynomial in the system size
and polynomial in the inverse precision
um
at the level of this talk this is the
resolution at which i'm going to be
talking about the complexity i'll just
say either if it's a polynomial you know
the exponential
um
and there's an additional advantage to
leaving things in this um less resolved
form because
as it turns out although there are other
quantum americans for um determine the
ground state energy uh that complexity
also takes this form um and so we can
roughly say that all four quantum
americans have costs which uh which look
like this um and for some summary of
these other algorithms you can read some
of the recent papers by len which are
very pedagogical in this
context
okay
so
so how does state preparation plus phase
estimation scale as a function of system
well uh it's clear that there is a piece
you know the phase estimation circuit
which is explicitly a polynomial in
system size
but this is also this prefactor this
polynomial inverse overlap and that can
also have a system size dependence
and in fact uh if one just considers
hilbert space as a function of system
size it's very large and and so if you
were just to prepare a random state
then it's then it's clear that the
overlap as an exponential that the
overlap of the random state with the
desired state typically has an
exponentially small overlap which would
create an exponential dependence on
system size here
um
and so the possibility of exponential
quantum variation therefore really
hinges on the complexity of state
preparation
and so really what we want to then
examine is whether quantum state
preparation
is in fact easy polynomially easy for
the class of generic chemical problems
while on the same problems
classical heuristics are exponentially
hard so that we get this eqa ratio
okay so sin state preparation is the key
step the key thing to examine we'll
we'll just look at some ways in which
people propose to prepare states
one of the simplest is
what it can be called anzac state
preparation um that's what i call it
and in this case you use some classical
approximation to the ground state
and
then you prepare the same state on the
quantum computer
now
there there's a sort of tricky
requirement here because uh you can if
you prepare this classical approximation
you need to make sure that it has
certain qualities
if you prepare the exact state
classically for example that would
that would basically mean that you don't
have to use a quantum computer or so so
you have to prepare a state that in in
some ways good and in some ways bad and
in particular you need to prepare a
state which has a pretty good overlap
because that is what determines the cost
of the subsequent quantum algorithm but
it can't have a very good energy
uh because then you wouldn't need the
quantum computer
um and and one way you could imagine
doing this for example is if you just
prepared a superposition of your ground
state and some arbitrarily high lying
excited state so that would have for
example good overlap because it has a
large component of the ground state but
because you mix in some very high lying
state it would then have a bad energy
um
so other combinations of qualities you
know are problematic right so if you
have a bad overlap plus a good energy
then that's very bad for the quant
computer because you know if you improve
your overlap your energy might become
exact okay so the real question is you
know do classical methods you know
typically yield states with the right
characteristics
and in this context um
often a very simple state is proposed as
the state one should prepare a single
determinant state or mean field or
hartree folk state
um and it's certainly true that if you
take a very small molecule uh the
hartree fox state often has a very good
overlap with the with the state that you
desire um and the energy is poor in the
sense that it is not sufficient for many
purposes uh uh many uh quantitative
purposes
um but eqa is really an asymptotic
statement and so so the question that we
really need to understand with respect
to unzip state preparation
is do
uh qualm chemistry methods usually
produce states with good overlap and bad
energies really for larger system sizes
so that's something we'll try to examine
today
another common uh
state preparation strategy is adiabatic
state preparation
um adiabatic state preparation relies on
the adiabatic theorem as the name
suggests
and the idea here is that you evolve
from some very simple initial state
whose ground state is very easy to
prepare
to your final state
and you can you evolve according to some
schedule where you change one into the
other
now if you do this infinitely slowly
then you will obtain the exact ground
state
now but in practice of course you only
have a finite amount of time
and the time scale over which you should
evolve this to get a reasonable overlap
with the desired final state
is determined by a quantity with the gap
the adiabatic gap
along this evolution path
now the fact that this that the time
depends on this gap uh immediately sort
of
makes this uh clearly a heuristic type
procedure because you you don't know a
priori you know what the gap will be or
how to construct a path where this gap
is not too small
um
and so for aj back state preparation to
be relevant to this eqa question then in
some sense
you you're assuming that it's easy to
find the path where the gap is not too
small where the gap is for example
larger than inverse polynomial system
size
it's
it's clear that this is not always going
to be true
so
for example
if you have a material or system which
has many competing ground states you can
imagine that some of the
transitions between these these ground
states will be first order and then and
one knows that as you go through first
order transition then typically the gap
vanishes exponentially in system size
so so one way to diagnose whether in
fact it is easy or not to find parts
with this type of protected gap
is to examine the initial state
dependence of adiabatic state
preparation
and so if it's if your
state preparation time
depends very strongly on your initial
hamiltonian it's very fine-tuned in that
sense
then
essentially this is a very heuristic
approach you have to give it a lot of
information to find the right initial
hamiltonian
um an example where this advanced state
preparation time is known to have a very
strong initial state dependence
is in the case of applying it to
unstructured search you know some type
of like grover search problems research
through the list and if you do this
through adiabatic computation then you
in fact know that the gap the minimum
gap in the problem
looks like one over the overlap of the
ground state of the initial hamiltonian
with the ground state of the final
hamiltonian in this case this is a
characterization of this strong initial
state dependence
so
so the basic
thing we have to understand here is as i
said how is it easy or difficult to find
good parts and if it's very difficult
then you know this is a very heuristic
method you have to give it a lot of
information and then it becomes
difficult to argue that it's really uh
better than classical heuristics because
you might be able to use that
information to improve the classical
heuristic as well so the question that
we're going to try and understand
is how heuristic is age of x state
preparation in generic or typical
quantum chemistry problems
okay so so that's sort of the numerator
the the at the various questions about
the numerator of the quantum ratio that
we want to understand and now let's just
talk about the denominator very briefly
so the denominator is going to be
classical heuristics
and we know that there are many
different heuristics that have been
proposed which are associated with
different electronic structure problems
um
there's a long list of names and you can
put even more on this list
and very roughly speaking one can
imagine the uh complex the the problem
space is divided into different domains
and different heuristics are sort of
cover different domains
so a critical question to ask of course
is is there anywhere in the space of
problems that people really care about
in chemistry and material science uh
where
one of these methods doesn't work and in
fact no method can be found that would
not require exponential cost so that's a
very very difficult question to answer
without in some sense studying every
problem
but what we can do is perhaps just look
at the problems that people typically
talk about and then see if in those
problems there is
any evidence of exponential hardness for
classical methods and and that is
something that we will
look at later
um
a second question which is is also
important which has not been studied
enough uh is that when one uses
classical heuristics you know once one
constructs them to have polynomial
runtime but of course you don't know the
error at the end right that's the nature
of the heuristic
um
but you can ask you know for some given
problem if if there's a tunable
parameter so you can you know improve
the error then then if i want to desire
precision then what is the cost you know
does this polynomial in l for example
become exponential now
and you know surprisingly this is
something that when we use classical
heuristics in in chemical street
simulations we don't usually ask this
question um and so not much is known
about it and so this is something that
we will also examine
so to summarize so far um
the eqa
the existence of ek it hinges on quantum
state preparation being polynomial easy
uh while classical heuristics for the
same problems are exponentially hard
and this is something that is quite hard
to study purely theoretically with the
tools of say just purely theoretical
computer science
because you know i've restricted myself
to some class of problems called generic
which i didn't define very clearly i'm
going to be comparing to heuristics
which are obviously hard to analyze
mathematically
and so the way in which you're going to
try and understand this is really
through numerical simulations to produce
evidence for one thing or another
and it's important to state at this
point that simulations you know they are
not same thing as proof right and and
many things are not clearly defined but
the way in which i'd interpret the
findings from this talk is that it
produces some evidence and at the end of
it we can weigh the evidence and decide
you know where we would like to place
our bets and that's the spirit in which
uh i'm going to be proceeding from here
okay so the numerical numerical
simulations will fall into two
categories the first set will be
concerned with the numerator okay so
we'll try and understand the ease and
heuristic nature of quantum state
preparation
and in particular i'm going to answer
some questions about unzip state
preparation so do quantum chemistry
methods produce states with good overlap
and bad energies
and is adiabatic state preparation
heuristic like a very heuristic thing or
is it sort of not very heuristic in
chemistry problems
um and uh i will answer these questions
in some simulations on some particular
problem the iron sulfur clusters of
nitrogenous
and then secondly for the denominator
which is the scaling of classical
heuristics in particular do we see
exponential
increase in complexity with system size
and you know what is the accuracy
dependence of classical heuristics for
this i'll look at some other systems
i'll look at some large molecules and a
variety of strongly correlated models
okay so so let me just start with the
iron sulfur clusters of nitrogenase and
you know these are very interesting
chemical problems i've worked on them
for many years
for the purposes of the talk however the
chemistry is completely unimportant so
they're just some things which look like
this
and they have uh they come in different
sizes um and the number of uh metals in
these iron sulfur clusters ranges from
um two to eight okay so you have small
clusters with two metals
and
the largest clusters have eight metals
um so one can construct a variety of
different representations of the
hamiltonians to describe these different
systems ranging from let's say a 40
qubit model to represent the smallest
cluster to about 150 qubits to represent
at the largest cluster
so as it turns out with today's sort of
classical algorithms one's able to
obtain reasonable approximations to
ground states across these systems um
and so what we're going to do
is we're going to look at these
approximate ground states you know that
so reasonably accurate um and then use
this to analyze some issues of qualm
state preparation that i've described so
the classical algorithm here for this in
this part of the talk is unimportant
just providing some uh some benchmark
data and we're going to use it to
understand state preparation
okay so first let's look at the unsat
state preparation technique
um
and
here i'm first going to try and prepare
the best possible slater determinant
state so this is some very simple
initial state but i'm going to prepare
it so that it has the best possible
overlap with the desired ground state
this is not exactly the state
preparation strategy that people usually
talk about where people prepare the
hartree folk state so hartree folk state
need not be the state with best op need
not be the slater determined state with
best overlap
and so what i'm doing here should be
preparing a state that's better than the
hartree fog state because it uses
information from the exact solution in
principle you know in practice you can't
actually do this but you know because
you don't have the exact state but i'm
just doing this to kind of present a
best-case scenario
okay so this is a plot of the um on the
y-axis is the overlap it's actually
overlapped square the weight uh and on
the x-axis is the size of the system as
measured by the number of metals
and
it's a log log plot so it's a log linear
plot and there's a linear relationship
there's many points because there's many
different flavors of these clusters
but unsurprisingly because hilbert's
space is getting very big uh the overlap
is decreasing exponentially uh with the
size of the with the size of system and
and it decreases quite quickly so by the
time one gets to
this type of cluster here you get to
quite small numbers you know like 10 to
the minus seven
um
and uh and since the uh cost of uh
of the quantum margin has an inverse
dependence on this y-axis
you know this is a large number
okay
um and so this just tells you that if i
prepare this kind of state that is
commonly discussed um it doesn't really
have the characteristic of uh i mean you
know the energies are not very good but
this doesn't have the characteristic of
having a good overlap it really has bad
overlap and just gets worse and worse um
and so of course this is problematic for
this way of preparing states
um
one might then say okay let's prepare a
better class of states you know maybe
you know these classical simulations are
not so hard in these systems well let's
use some better classical simulation for
example let's prepare a matrix prostate
um in that case of course you can
improve the overlap
and indeed perhaps you could obtain some
overlap such that you know if one looks
at this ratio carefully the quantum rate
quantum cost versus class cost there
could be some quantum advantage for some
fixed size
but at least for some fixed
parameterization
this exponential decrease in the overlap
is a pretty uh
it's a pretty generic sort of phenomenon
and so asymptotically this strategy will
still be problematic
so then one can consider instead
adiabatic state preparation
um
and uh just
to to say a little bit more about you
know a bit more precise about what we're
going to consider uh will a backstage
preparation depends on the initial
choice of the hamiltonian and the way in
which you change it into the final
hamiltonian and we're going to just
consider in the numerics a linear
interpolation path
now
we're going to evolve for a certain
amount of time
and we want to obtain some desired
fidelity and you have to specify this
fidelity of course to to know how how
long you want to evolve for
and so we're going to
consider the adiabatic state preparation
time so that the final fidelity uh with
the true wave function is 75 is three
quarters
now the way in which you would determine
this numerically is you should run a
time dependent uh quantum simulation on
the you know do this classically one
would solve the time dependent uh
schrodinger equation and just run this
with different times and then find the
time where you get where you get this 75
overlap but as it turns out a much
simpler quantity which is just the
adiabatic estimate coming from the
adiabatic theorem is actually very
accurate
in this problem to obtain this 75
fidelity so here i show the the uh
relationship between the explicit the
time dependence simulations of the
adiabatic state preparation time to get
75 percent weight versus the age bag
estimate and the important point is that
these dots here this ratio is close to
one right it's order one um and so since
it's much easier to compute this
adiabatic estimate uh this is what we're
going to use as the estimate of time
so we're going to do this for by one of
those smaller iron sulfur clusters
because these things are quite expensive
um and we're going to consider the
dependence on the initial choice of
initial hamiltonian to understand how
heuristic this process is
um and we're
going to consider two families of
initial hamiltonians we're going to
consider different mean field
hamiltonians
um in the mean field hamiltonians you
can think about the uh the ground state
as filling up different single particle
levels and one can just shift the
energies of these levels so that
different orbitals are filled in the
ground state so you can change the
occupancy so that's how i generate many
meaningful hamiltonians
and i'll also consider another class of
hamiltonians which are interacting
hamiltonians
but rather but they restrict the
interactions in the qubits to be in a
subset of the qubit so you know if i had
all the interactions you just have the
exact time of turn but maybe i just
consider some small window
okay
so given those two families then we can
ask you know what is is the state
preparation time very dependent on the
choice of initial hamiltonian
um and so this is a plot of the
various state preparation times across
all the different hamiltonians we
considered
and and you see on the y-axis here is
the uh
is the time and it's it's a logarithmic
axis and there's many many you know goes
from
ranges from 10 to zero to 10 to eight
right so it's many many decades of time
and so
it seems that there is a strong initial
hamiltonian dependence
now on the
x-axis is some other quantity
and you see that in this plot there
there's a kind of linear relationship
um
now uh what is this quantity on the
x-axis it's actually the
overlap of the ground state of the
initial hamiltonian with the ground
state of the desired hamiltonian so some
kind of state overlap
um and this relationship here tells you
that in fact the the gap along the age
of eight cost which determines the state
preparation time actually has some
dependence some strong correlation uh
with this overlap
um
it's it's also important to to note that
finding one of the initial hamiltonians
with one of these short preparation
times is not very easy um
so if i were to just take the hartree
fog state so that is the state with
hearty fog hemorrhaging so that produces
the
state with the lowest mean field energy
that in fact has a very long ago back
state preparation time it's actually
longer than the time you need for phase
estimation at least to reach the this
desired precision
um
so overall this this suggests that in
fact aj backstage preparation in this
part this problem here but this problem
is not chosen to be particularly special
actually has a very high very heuristic
character it's very not easy to find a
good starting point or good path and and
this strong dependence is obviously
problematic if it extends to larger
systems if you don't give yourself more
information
um
i'm not claiming here it's important to
note that that you can't prepare these
kind of physical states adiabatically
i'm only claiming that you need
it's it's difficult to do so without
putting in more structure into the
problem and then of course when you put
in that structure you might be able to
use that structure classically
okay so so that's you sort of the
numerator examined okay so uh
the basic things that we see are the
following so we don't see that quantum
chemistry methods produce states with
good overlap and bad energies in larger
systems and adi backstage preparation
seems to require a lot of heuristic kind
of information
so now let's look at the denominator
which is the scaling of classical
heuristics
and for this as i said we'll look at
some large molecules and correlated
models
okay so um
so i'll first look at a set of systems
that you know are of interest in variety
of applications so organic molecules and
biomolecules
and many of the molecules in this sort
of this class of chemistry um are what
we call single reference in character
and this is just a way of characterizing
the ground states we expect uh in
particular those those ground states are
expected to have a good local overlap uh
with i mean with the standard mean field
state a hundred folk state
so under this setting there's a variety
of class heuristics which are often
quite successful
and one such heuristic is this so-called
couple cluster theory
where you construct your ground state by
the exponential of some operator acting
on the hartree fog mean field state
and this circle cluster operator
generates excitations uh what we call
particle excitation
so
so this cluster operator can generate
one particle hold two particle and so on
and so forth and particle excitations
and if i truncate the level of
excitation then explicitly you obtain a
a then explicitly this method is a
heuristic that is polynomial cost and
system size
um but of course we don't know what the
error is so it's without guaranteed
error
so the question then is if i actually
would require desired precision so that
i can really
talk you know compare the complexity to
the quantum case then what is the
computational scaling
now as it turns out
you know people have been doing couple
cluster calculations for
50 years
almost
and and there's a lot of data out there
and although people don't analyze this
question explicitly in fact all the data
is available to analyze this question in
the literature and so
um and so uh what i did was i went to
look back at some of my my own
uh calculations with in collaboration
with some people 20 years ago mihai
kelly and jurgen gauss or the other
authors and i just sort of replotted it
to look at this question
um and so here i show a calculation on a
small molecule this is the n2 molecule
the nitrogen molecule
and here's a plot of the error versus a
computational cost by some metric and
it's a log blog plot
and you see a linear relationship
so what this implies is that in fact the
cost to obtain a given precision is
inverse polynomial in the error for this
molecule
okay so this is a finding for a specific
molecule but then one can try and
generalize it
and the specific form of the couple
cluster wave function basically says
that if i now take this molecule
and replicate it so i don't just have a
nitrogen molecule but i have a gas of
nitrogen many nitrogen molecules then
using the same unzips
you obtain now a fixed relative
precision across this assembly of many
molecules so this is just a mathematical
property of the answers known as
extensivity
and so then what this says is that you
know since the algorithm is explicitly
polynomial cost
and as the system size increases you you
reach a polynomial inverse error in the
relative precision then this is sort of
you know the cost for couple cluster for
many n2 molecules and then because
everything is polynomial cost you can
just convert that also into absolute
precision with just polynomial overhead
and so this would be the scaling the
computational scaling for a gas of n2
molecules for absolute precision and one
might then conjecture that this is in
fact the scaling in general for couple
cluster
for this so-called single reference
family of problems
okay so so we want to then
sort of uh
look at this empirically over a wider
set of systems and see if this holds and
for that one it has to introduce
another heuristic so that one can
actually do other
other large calculations and i won't go
into those in detail but i'll just show
some results so so this is couple
cluster with an additional local
heuristic and and we can look for
example how the cost scales in see
what the error is
so here i consider this the set of
organic molecules and so these are just
molecules of lots and lots of carbon
atoms and hydrogen atoms and i make a
very long chain of them and and here on
the x-axis the chain length is
increasing y-axis is the computational
cost and it's explicitly polynomial cost
and so you see here this is in fact very
close to linear cost because of the
local heuristic but the important point
is this inset which shows the area of
the method
now in these large molecules we we don't
know what the exact answer is but we do
have experimental measurements of
certain quantities and this is the
experimental measurement of the heat of
formation and essentially this is this
is the error relative to the theoretical
result and you so and this shows that
this error is essentially constant as
the system size increases and it's below
the number one one is a typical desired
precision in this quantity so the one is
essentially seeing here that the
calculation is polynomial cost and
system size for fixed uh relative
precision
um
and uh you know the same algorithms can
be used in more exotic things right so
this is a very simple chain but you can
also do this in biomolecules and so on
and these calculations are affordable
and have similar error scaling
characteristics
okay so so that's one class of
large systems and now let me move to
another class that people often discuss
which are so-called strongly correlated
materials
so strongly correlated materials are
challenging for classical ab initial
methods but it's important to note that
such calculations are becoming
increasingly accessible so
so more and more correlated materials
are being simulated with some success
um
but to to discuss sort of the scaling of
cost and scale and precision it's very
difficult to to just talk about ab
initial things because everything is
very complicated so so we will use as a
proxy first low energy models of
correlated materials and this is this
simplification from the app initial
calculation to this simpler model is
very similar to what i did on these iron
sulfur clusters earlier where i just
considered a certain number of the orbit
tools
so two of the models that we'll consider
are the heisenberg model which is a spin
model of typically used to describe
magnetism
and the hubbard model which is a
fermionic model which is usually taken
as a model of many correlated electron
materials such as a high temperature
superconductors
and
and i'm going to consider these models
at various points in the phase diagram
for various system sizes where the exact
almost exact data or exact data is
available because i want to understand
the precision
and so for this i have to choose a
classical heuristic and there's many
heuristics that one could use but the
heuristic that i'm going to show next
few slides is a tensor network heuristic
and i won't get into any of the details
but tensor networks you can think in
this context are just a variational
unzips for quantum states which obey
some which have some locality associated
with them some area law like properties
and the number of variational parameters
in the in in this unsets this polynomial
in some parameter called d which is
called the bond dimension
and
and these answers by construction uh
display some type of area law for the
entanglement entropy
now this is a heuristic
and the heuristic enters in various ways
one way in which it enters is that to do
calculations with tensor networks you
have to contract these mathematical
tensors together to get to get some
numbers out um and in the general case
of tensor networks this contraction um
you know exactly is exponentially hard
but one can construct a variety of
approximate algorithms for contraction
in this case we'll use a tensor network
known as peps together with an
approximate contraction algorithm which
is explicitly polynomial cost in the
system size and polynomial plus in this
variant in the number of variational
parameters although of course we don't
know the error so we're going to use a
scheme a heuristic that is polynomial
cost by construction
okay
so let's now look at this for the 3d
three-dimensional heisenberg model and
here we're using a three-dimensional
tensor network
um and the left-hand plot i'm just
verifying that the cost is indeed
polynomial in system size i mean this
should be true because it's the way it's
constructed but that's we see in fact
that indeed as a system this is a log
log plot and you have a linear
relationship so it's a polynomial and
it's very flat in fact this so this this
implies that it's sort of close linear
uh in the cost gain is closely linear in
system size
but more importantly is the error
because we don't know the error a per
array and on the right hand side they
show the error a relative error as a
function of system size up to a thousand
sites and you show that the relative
error is very constant
so from this we observe that the cost is
polynomial on system size close to
linear system size
for some uh at least over this range of
problems
for some constant relative precision
okay so then how does a precision scale
and so for this i go to some other data
and so i here i look at a fermionic
model a 2d hubbard model
where we have some very accurate data
from a variety of other methods
and these plots show that show the
precision as a function of the number of
variational parameters with this this
parameter d here
and this is a this is in fact a log-log
plot you see a linear relationship
and this is telling you that the
relative precision is scaling as an
inverse polynomial of the number of
parameters and since the cost of the
calculation is polynomial in the number
of parameters this means that the cost
overall is in is polynomial in the
inverse precision relative position
okay so the observed empirical scaling
of this tensor network in these models
is then something that looks polynomial
in system size and polynomial uh in the
inverse relative precision
okay so so those are of course models
and one might then ask well you know but
really you know most of the time
chemistry concerns more realistic
simulations
but it's important to note that models
are of course derived from from the real
world um so if one takes a
one-dimensional hybrid model it's a very
simple model of electrons with some
on-site coulomb term and some nearest
neighbor hopping but if you just add
some longer range hoppings and some
longer range coulomb you have a
representation essentially of hydrogen
atoms
and if you add more terms you can
represent other types of systems as well
so for example if you have the hub with
more than two dimensions and you
introduce a few more orbitals and
introduce you know a few other degrees
of freedom then you have a model of the
cube superconductors
and historically methods that work with
models essentially graduate after a
number of years
sometimes it can be many years
from the models to ab initio
calculations for example this happened
with dmrg over at some time in the 90s
and with various quantum monte carlo
methods for example dynamical mean field
theory and and tensor networks of the
kind that are showing you are also
undergoing this transition uh in modern
times and
and the experience is that at least in
the cases that i've described uh moving
from models to ab initio calculations
does increase the complexity
but so far i'm not aware that there is
any empirical evidence that the
complexity suddenly changes from these
sort of polynomial like scaling
characteristics to an exponential
scaling
and just like and this example of
one such ab initial correlated uh
calculation with now a different
heuristic uh quantum embedding
um
i won't go into how embedding works in
any detail is just some heuristic which
assembles observables in some large
problem from many small couple
calculations that coupled together uh in
smaller problems one can do some ab
initial analog of the of the
heisenberg models and hubbard models i
showed just now so these are
three-dimensional ab initio calculations
on hydrogen cubes and hydrogen sheets
and again one can assemble a plot which
indicates that the cost scaling is
polynomial and system size
and the relative precision is constant
as the calculation uh
size as the problem size increases
okay so that brings me to pretty much
the end of all the data uh
in the second half basically at least
for the problems that people commonly
discuss um you know it's not clear if
there are other problems but for those
problems we have yet to see an
exponential dependence on system size in
many of the classical heuristics that
people use sorry garnet there's there's
a question in the chat maybe
i wonder if you can address it it's
antonio
uh
capo who says um
yes about about this um you know
bounding the energy yes you where you
know the bounds from below you can bound
the error but
what about uh
when you do i so this is a question
about assessing error
yeah okay well um if the error if the
okay so
i'm almost done maybe i've just got one
more one
one more slide but
let me just
finish the talk and i will address the
question yeah okay so um so just to
summarize uh we examined the evidence
for the eqa hypothesis
um
and you know again i will reiterate that
this requires quantum state preparation
to be
exponentially easier than class
heuristics on the same set of problems
and for this polynomial to exponential
ratio we want classical risks to be
exponentially hard
so
what the simulations do is they raise
questions about whether the state
preparation is you know truly
exponentially easier
and we don't observe in the class of
problems that we saw
exponential hardness of the classical
heuristics
and so i'll finish by also emphasizing
that this is by no means a proof
and certainly we cannot rule out eqa in
other cases
um
but you can weigh the evidence and at
least as far as and this is now my
opinion
as far as i see i think it's at least a
prudent uh prudent uh point of view to
assume that exponential quantum
advantage is not generically available
in this task so that's the
main conclusion from this talk
and there are often many questions
uh and here are some
frequently asked questions um and
one of the most
commonly asked questions is does this
imply that there is no use of qom
computers you know assuming that the
point of view i'm proposing is the
correct one doesn't mean quan computers
are not useful for chemistry
and the answer to that is no because
x-men asymptotic exponential advantage
is not in fact required for quantum
americans to be useful
in fact in the classical world any
improvement in algorithms is almost
always a polynomial improvement and
that's still considered an advance so
that's i would say an important
point to remember
okay thank you so that's the end um and
uh
i can
then answer questions i can start with
antonio's question great well thanks uh
thanks a lot ghana that was a fantastic
talk uh yeah so um
uh
i i guess tauren could you uh
could you moderate the
chat please
yeah sure
um
okay
so
uh do you do you want me to ask the
first question okay yes okay so i can
just ask a question so um okay so and uh
so antonio
so hello antonio is uh asking the
question um
it should be fair to say out loud if the
method considered abounded from below by
the true ground state energy
and and how do you assess the error for
methods that are now not bound from
below or do you compare with experiments
okay so um okay so i think this is
getting at an important point which is
that everything i've just in many ways
one one is that um i've been comparing
to uh sort of rigorous quantum
algorithms where you have some sort of
some rigorous things to say about the
error
and in the classical heuristic you do
not always have rigorous things to say
about the error so
one of the things you can say is if you
use a variational algorithm the error is
above
that of the
energies above that of the true energy
and
out of the data that i showed
modulo some
subtlety which i'm happy to address the
tensor network algorithm might be
considered the variation the tensor
network heuristic might be considered a
variational outcome the couple cluster
energies are not strictly variational
although in all these types of single
reference problems they typically are
variational
the question is then if it's not
variational how do you assess the error
it and that's really just i would say
generally to how you assess the aero
heuristics and so the way you do so is
of course in smaller problems you you
benchmark against exact calculations
um
and in larger problems uh you have no
guarantee right and that's and but you
have to as so usually you have infer the
behavior from larger systems from
smaller systems where you can do careful
benchmarking
okay second question to him s hello to
him are the problems that are typically
solved classically
biased
towards poli-l and will not lend
themselves to eqa
that is if i understand correctly uh
an insightful question
which is that
um it may well be that
problems typical problems of chemistry
you know for example they exhibit some
type of locality
and things that exhibit some type of
locality mean that
in some ways you don't have a dependence
on the total problem you don't have it
depends on the total hillbilly size
hilbert space size and so they're not
very conducive to eqa so that is i think
indeed a relevant observation
let me see
says uh you seem to say eager a requires
good quantum state preparation but one
can also make states close to say
the first excited state with very little
overlap with the ground state and
students still do well in quantum phase
estimation the first excited state is
close enough in energy right
uh so i have enough yes that's correct
you can you don't you can if you're just
looking at the quality of the ground the
eigenvalue you can prepare states you
can just have some overlap with the
low-lying states
um
but uh that doesn't itself remove the
concerns that uh
are in this talk
i think okay
some other questions in the chat as well
i can read them out
okay
yeah so uh one is can you comment so
this is bastion brahms can you comment
please on the empirical practical
scaling of fci qmc methods of allah v
booth and tom
the empirical practical scaling okay so
so fci qmc
is a method which has
two flavors
the first flavor is called fci qmc by
itself right
and that has an exponential scaling with
system size
but
essentially all the time
um
unless you magically find a sign-free
problem for it
but the
uh there's another variant known as the
initiator version um and the initiative
version the the scaling may be more mild
but
i don't think it's been very well
characterized and my suspicion is that
it's still exponential
great
i believe steve steve flania has a has a
question steve do you want to
just
yourself
yeah sure um hi garnet thanks for the
nice talk i appreciate the um
skeptical take on quantum advantage um i
do think there may be a potential
weakness in your argument with respect
to
um
the ground state overlap uh part of your
argument
so what you're arguing about is
uh basically
the um so we use overlap as a way to
prove that our algorithms work
but it's not necessarily true
i mean that's a sufficient condition for
us to show that our algorithms work in
most cases
so um i mean just a really simple
example
is if i gave you just a paramagnet um
and i
prepare the ground state all spins up
but then i tweak each spin by epsilon
then the overlap with the true ground
state is exponentially small in the
system size but all the course
properties that i'm interested in
estimating from the system i'll be able
to recover so often we prove things that
we can
you know we prove that our algorithm
works by studying things like overlaps
but often those aren't really the
questions that we're probing in true
algorithms so i'm wondering if you're
sort of comparing a bit
against the straw man by showing that
yes indeed the overlap is going to be
very small
um
i mean i would just be curious about
what your thoughts are on that
yeah i think you're pointing out um
i mean i don't disagree with you but i
mean uh
it's it's exactly the reason why
classical algorithms work is precisely
because of the intuition that you have
stated right so so now it's because what
you're saying is typically true that you
that you can act that these there is
this type of locality so if you have
good so long as you have these good
local overlaps
the fact that they multiply out to zero
is not very important i mean that's
essentially what classical heuristics
use but the point is that you know that
type of property can be used classically
as well
so that the exponential quantum
advantages
is uh
is unlikely right right uh i yeah i
agree i'm just wondering if um
there aren't
other scenarios where you get a quantum
advantage even though
maybe it's
hard to get uh an adequate
classical advantage from using this fact
yeah i don't know it seems it seems like
an open question to me that's an open
question so in other words you can start
to make heuristic americans for example
which start to take advantage of this
property and it's quite possible that
you'll have uh quantum advantage in
those cases um the question though is
is we don't know what those are i mean
those arguments haven't yet been
formulated right those are not the ones
i'm carrying against but also there's
also a question of whether you expect
exponential advantage in those cases
versus
your advantage
okay thanks a lot
great i think uh ike chong also has a
question
yeah thanks gamesh garnet i really
enjoyed your talk and i find your
argument quite convincing
and so maybe much like steve i'm
interested in trying to change the
question
and i'm curious about your opinion
i i suspect that there will be a
different flavor of questions for which
there can be quantum advantage and my
flavor of choice is decision questions
that is what is the color of the paint
what is the smell of the chemical
and i'm curious for your opinion do you
believe that that might lead to a better
possibility or probability for for a
quantum advantage
um i so in a strict sense i mean
yes right you can
formulate um
say
um some bqp decision problem as a ground
state or some hamiltonian
and
so clearly finding the trying that you
know finding this ground state
uh shouldn't be classically easy right
so right so formulate these things so
that it's true the question is of course
whether those
problems are the ones you know of course
one of the questions that we ask and i i
don't
know i mean my
you know my my personal opinion is
many problems may not
really fall into that type but you know
i yes i don't have a
yeah i don't really know the answer yeah
so i mean like theoretically yes but in
practice i don't know
it it seems to me that maybe quantum
chemists have gotten addicted to asking
for ground state energies
and so i'm hoping to convince some more
chemists to think of decision questions
that would be worthy
and and and interesting that are hard
for them currently but might be easy for
quantum computers particularly because
algorithms quantum algorithms often seem
to uh like to give qubit type responses
such as the singular value transform
algorithm
and this is the origin for my my hope
here i see yeah it's very interesting i
mean part of this reflects just my
ignorance and what decision pro like
what kind of problem you know i think of
bqp in my my
my encounter with that is like quantum
dynamics and i'm sort of less familiar
with what kind of interesting decision
problems you know like are there in b2b
thank you you actually sound more like a
computer scientist than a chemist in
your answer so i appreciate that i'm
pretending to be one just for this talk
yeah
uh sergio has a comment or question uh
do you want to ask directly sergio
oh sure
yeah
sorry i don't know if you can hear me
yes yes now i didn't click
hi garnet
yeah uh i think that
you make you know to make the case that
tensor networks and peps in particular
can solve generic chemistry and physics
in polynomial time which you know it's
an hypothesis that has been around but i
think you're making this claim
video on it hypothesis is you know uh
congestion i guess now
um you're extrapolating from
uh
my concern is about the relative error
scaling with the
bond dimension and i think the data is
also consistent i mean i don't know
what's the scaling but
what i see is that the data
is inconclusive is also consistent with
an exponential scaling of a relative
error with one dimension and furthermore
they're extrapolating from one dimension
a to infinity and from quasi-1d to 3d
and from you know translation and
invariant to
cases which are not translational
environment and can be closer to spin
glasses so you're doing you know like a
big extrapolation we think occlusive
data in my view so i guess i'm you know
i don't know what the the truth is i
don't know
if the hypothesis is that you know
tensor networks are pretty normal is
true or not but i'm a bit skeptical
about all these extrapolations so i
guess my question is if you want to
comment on this or at least i will just
you know put it out that i mean there
are all these extrapolations in the way
yeah i mean okay so i think this relates
to
um
this really so
i i mean there are various statements
that you made which are not technically
correct right so for example there is no
translational invariance in these
calculations and so on and so forth and
the plot again or against
exponential
does not really look like a line and so
and so forth but but i completely agree
nonetheless with a bigger point that
you're trying to make which is that
the
data is limited
and it's limited both in the systems
that are studied and it is limited in
the
uh you know the size and scale and and
so and so forth and so this doesn't
really constitute a proof but the point
is simply that it could have been one
could have obtained a very different
outcome so for example one could have in
fact seen very clear evidence of
exponential scaling
um with system size
for fixed precision
um so for some much of your question is
about for the precise precision
dependence but for fixed precision
it's really clear that you don't see
this exponential dependence and it's not
just for tensor networks i showed this
also for another class of paragraphs
and i agree even something else
i think for fixed precision these
algorithms are going to be polynomial
i think that's true yeah so the point is
that one could
one could have seen different evidence
and
so
so you one can say that this evidence is
insufficient because you know that's a
that's a reason it's reasonable to be
skeptical in the other direction but i
think to be a strong proponent of eq and
there's problems one has to actually
come up with some positive evidence that
uh
that to support the case
i guess what i'm saying when you look at
relative energy as a function of one
dimension it's also consistent with
exponential it's not like uc is
polynomial you know it could be
exponential if you plot it in a
different way it's also a straight line
in a similar plot that's well i mean you
know
this is
just not the case right but if you we
but what is certainly true is if you
look at these things here
this is a very small range um and one
can argue about whether this is truly
linear um and that much i think that is
this is this is true so the statement
that this looks like poly one over d or
probably one of epson has to be taken
with a grain of sword given that this
range is small and that is a fair fair
point
uh to make if you brought it
looks also as a straight line
i mean sergio you have sent me the plot
and i've i mean i i've looked at it and
you know
this one looks like they have it doesn't
i don't know what to say i mean it's
very difficult without showing it
but the data is you know the data we're
available and people can plot them and
they can make make a decision i suppose
thank you
[Music]
this is a very thought-provoking talk
and uh
yeah i think we all need to to think a
lot more about all the things he raised
um
but one way that we might be able to
you know avoid
hypotheticals we can talk about things
that we have today are cold atom
simulators right which are imperfectly
controllable
and
they can simulate
okay admittedly they're simulating
things with the hamiltonian the target
hamiltonian is pretty close to the
system hamiltonian nevertheless they're
controllable they can tell us about the
phase diagram of things like the unitary
fermi gas uh tren you know charge and
spin transport um all in regimes that
we
uh i mean i don't argue with your class
but we don't know how to we don't know
how to find those things classically
right yeah yeah so the question is
um how does this fit your picture do you
think that you know digital aquatic
computers won't be able to achieve the
same thing or maybe we could improve the
classical algorithms which haven't tried
hard enough uh yeah well that's so very
interesting so i want to
i want to emphasize that the fact that
there is an exponential quantum
advantages doesn't mean that
things can be practical classically
right so
uh there could be an enormous polynomial
barrier
separating us from any
from any real results and and in my view
that's in practice
the case for you know if you ask well if
i'm saying you know class garbage is so
good why can't you just solve everything
classically well in many cases there's
an enormous polynomial barrier even if
it even if it's not exponential but but
so that's one point the other thing is
that called atom simulators in fact
already illustrate some of the
um
challenges that
quantum americans have with ground state
problems i think you may for example be
aware with some experiments with for
example ripper gaston arrays like lucan
and so and so forth where
um
you know
some of the experiments
are essentially preparing metastable
states because the adiabatic state
preparation protocol is just not going
slowly enough
and the numerics you know shows that in
fact the state they prepare is not the
ground still the hamiltonian and so you
know they start you start to be able to
re you know
experimentally examine problems of state
preparation
uh which is which is quite interesting
but but i mean i think that you know if
i had a quantum computer tomorrow or a
cold atom simulator on my desk you know
i would be using it for lots and lots of
things
i'm sure it has many useful applications
and many things that would not be
possible classically i have no doubt
it's just whether these separations we
should really be thinking about those
exponential separations or polynomial
separations which is really
i think the question i want to raise
great
[Music]
and we can't do it on a classical
computer like yeah i mean i guess it's
true it could be we could say if it's an
end to the 10th separation it could be
that too but yeah all right
right
great um
so
um it seems there's a there there are a
lot of uh you know it's a it's very
thought-provoking uh talk so
what we could do now is move on to the
panel and then
come back to any any more questions from
the audience uh you know towards the end
of the panel
so if you could have the
the
videos pin for the panelists
um
okay so uh
so i should say we have a we have a
really
you know a great panel that comes at
these questions from
from